hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round four of the 2018
single Cup between Fabiano Caruana
and Hikaru Nakamura now it's a very
interesting game because it kind of
brings up the same position on the board
that was in round 2 of the sinful cup
between Magnus Carlsen and Sergei
hurricane but through a different move
order but you'll see what I mean when we
get to it before we check out the game
we do have a nice photo challenge who is
the gentleman in the photo here there
you have it we have spoken of him very
often on my channel so I'm sure most of
you will know who the gentleman is and
we do have a nice photo of this
encounter there you have it
karmana is arriving at the board
Nakamura shaking his hand the red bull
opened and ready and although all you
have said in the comments that he
actually does drink it I've I've I have
yet to see it and here we have also a
very nice photo by Fabiano Khurana I was
taken by Leonard totes but it kind of
does seem like he was taken by Nakamura
after Khurana said at the table you know
like if Nakamura wanted to have a photo
of all of his victims but you know
things don't always go as you want them
to go so let's check out this game
Khurana Alec we said had the white
pieces and he opened with the d4 we have
90 to f6 c4 e6 Knight to f3 and d5
transposing into the Queens gambit
declined Knight to c3 Bishop to e7
we have g3 the chapters on c4 Bishop to
G - we have castles nice to e5 and now
Knight to c6
we have Bishop captures on c6 pawn
captures the knight captures Queen to e8
and now Knight captures on e7 Queen
captures on e7 and now Queen to a4 so if
you remember the similar idea was in the
cousin Cara King game but there this
pawn was on a3 the pond was on a 3
because the dark square bishop sorry
about this the dark square bishop before
being developed to e7 first Kerrigan
played Bishop to b4 then cross son
played a3 and then car cane retreated it
to e7 so pretty much
the same idea Knight captures Queen
captures Queen to a4 similar the same as
in the cross and kurakin game and c5
again the same move the capture screen
captures Bishop to e3 the same like the
move cousin played Queen to c7 the same
as cracker I can replied here we have
the difference like we said this pawn
was on a3 now this one is on a 2 so
Khurana doesn't go for cousins move rook
to d1 rather here karana castles Queen
side so what's the difference difference
here can Nakamura take advantage of this
the King does seem to be you know not
too comfortable there but as you'll see
it's not all that clear Knight to g4 I
move Quran of course had to take into
consideration because now the bishop is
under attack Knight captures on e3 would
double white spawns and here
Carson's idea of transferring the bishop
to d4 wouldn't really make sense because
of because of a 5 you can simply pull
the bishop back even if 95 attacking the
Queen Queen d7 attacks the knight the
bishop is also under attack you would
still have to bring it back and then
Knight captures or F captures for
example captures captures and Queen f6
when an attack on the f2 point would be
will be alright for black so here after
Knight g4 Khurana came really prepared
no doubt he had this position on the
board before the the game even started
rook to be two he allows this doubling
of pawns on the e-file and prepares to
double up rooks on the D file Knight
captures F captures and now rook to b8
of course nakamura wants to create some
sort of an attack against this this king
and the Queen side are rock h2 b 1
karana continues with his playing
doubles rooks and now a5 also an idea
seems like you really want this bishop
to be on f5 to slice all the way to be 1
but even if you prepare this for example
a5 Queen a3 preparing to bring more
protection to the b-pawn also Queen d7
is an idea now bushel 5 you do get this
diagonal but white can always counter it
with E 4 Bishop e6 and the now rock to
d6 would be would be very nice for white
so after rook H to d1 we have a five
king to be one and now h6 came to a one
and now rook to be for Queen to c2
wakaru wanna and now look back to b8
Queen to e4 Bishop to b7 developing the
bishop wouldn't attack on the Queen
Queen d4 and now comes Bishop to a eight
we have E 4 and rook F to c8 and here
comes Queen to f2 a very nice move
of course you could go for something
like Queen to d7 to immediately grab
hold of the seventh rank but after Queen
to b6 you would black would of course
decline the trade of Queens rook F one
we're gonna attack against the f7 pawn
now Rock the c7 defending Queen before
of our trade of Queens now comes Queen B
4 and the black would definitely hold
his own here so I have to look after c8
Queen to after was played by Caruana
and now rook to d7 is a pretty big
threat because then Queen captures on f7
would be unstoppable you would have to
give up the Queen so be sure to see sex
preventing the rope from coming to d7
Queen to c5 and now comes Bishop to 8
offering a trade of Queens also Nakamura
could have kept the pressure with a for
preparing a 3 and after a 3 Queen to b7
again keeping the pressure on the board
not allowing this rook to move but he
preferred to prefers this simplification
with the trade of Queens brush up to e8
we have quick after send the rook
captures now the rope is already
guarding the 7th rank and and he seems
to have a nice position here rook to d6
if you look at this position of the
material on the board is completely
equal and Nakamura has a bishop against
a knight so far it's not it's not that
great of a bishop but if he manages to
activate it as the pawns are on both
sides of the board a black should be
better here and the black has a better
pawn structure so both players have
three point islands you can see here one
two three and one two three four black
but White has doubled epon so everything
tells us that black should be better
here but White's
control of the D file and the double
roofs there give actually y to the
advantage
it's okay King to a fate I bring the
King into the game now comes rook to a
sex attacking the a5 pawn rook the c5
defending it rook to a7 preparing group
to f1 perhaps and not allowing this
bishop to really move doesn't really
have anywhere to move but for example if
it if it went somewhere then rooked d7
would also could also be an idea
rogue beat the c8 here Nakamura defends
the c4 pawn with the other look so this
rook can start going going going places
a king be one Rock to h5 attacking the h
2 upon H 4 and now rook to e5 attacking
the TT pawn so now the knight cannot
move we have king to see - and now comes
g5 rook to f1 we have King to g7 and the
now comes rook to b7 King to g6 and now
King to d2 we have f5 and now comes HP
after sin g5 and here you have a choice
do you want to capture this with the h1
do you want to capture the the e pawn
would be F pawn if you capture this then
you get a rope - h1 with ideas of this
rope coming here
so after Bishop to c6 attacking the rook
rook comes to H h 7f captures on e4 and
now King to e3 about after King to a5
you know it's not it's not all that
great of a position for the black king
to be in so instead after this H captors
and g5 Nakamura played F captures on e4
but it doesn't help the black all that
much King to e3 first now comes bishop
the c6 would an attack on the rook rook
the rook to e7 and now rook captures and
g5 captures any sex with check we have
King to g7 and now rook to e7 with check
King to g6 and the now rook to d1 are
preparing to bring the other look over
to d6
King to f6 with an attack on the rook
rook to e7 and now King to e6 here rube
back to h1 threatening to capture adh
pawn and here you could thrice try
something like rook address and g3 with
check but after King d4
for example rook to b8 you could also
give another check but after king
captures on c-4 you'd still have to deal
with this each point Rock to g6
defending now rope would capture on a5
and again white would get so much
material and end up in in most likely a
winning position so after rook to h1 h5
Nakamura decides to defend eh pawn at g4
and now Bishop to ei t' pawn captures
Bishop captures and now comes Knight
captures on e4 so here karmana nicely
grabs upon rook to f5 and here white is
in a completely winning position for
example you could go rook to d1
threatening rook to d6 check and now
it's not all that easy white would a
black would have to play a passive move
like rope to c6 but then the rock is
coming to d7 or if you play a weaker
move like rook to e5 then white will
simply drive you into being checkmated
King h3 you can check here the nice and
the knight and rooks are really
harmonious here rook to have to check he
moves now look to f4 there is no defense
against rook to h4 check checkmate you
would have to give up a lot of material
to avoid this
so after this rook to fi move Nakamura
the karana didn't go for this rook to d1
idea he went for a more human approach
rook to a6 check and here we even have a
photo of this moment here you have it
karana just delivered the check and
Nakamura is you know considering what to
do with this King there you have it the
king is in the photo the King is on a
lights were on d7 it seems like King to
d7 was the idea but it was not actually
played perhaps Nakamura just brought it
to d7 and still he still hold it and he
was considering what to do but it
wouldn't it wouldn't be all that great
because here you would simply get Knight
to f6 check with a double attack against
the bishop here and you'll lose a piece
here or you have to capture and then you
lose the exchange another idea instead
of king to d7 you could also try King to
f7 but then this comes with check you
lose a full rock here
also after rook to a sex check aside
from King d7 and King ff7 you have King
e5 but again it doesn't help you
rook captures on h5 rook captures rook
captures and if I would check King moves
and rope captors here
you're on down a piece and of course
white is completely winning here so
after rook to a6 check Nakamura probably
did this like we saw in the photo and
then us all the other variations played
King g7 but again it doesn't help 9th to
d6 the move is very simple you attack
the rooks rope the destructor e6 check
e5 check and now King to be for both
rooks are under attack there is nothing
to do here
you could try rook c5 but then white can
simply white can simply grab grab here
and it's a completely winning position
for white so yeah after this Knight to
d6 move rook to e5 king before Nakamura
resigned the game and this is Nakamura's
second loss in a row so definitely not
the greatest definitely not the greatest
moment for him in the tournament but you
know it's still early in the tournament
there are still a lot of time to recover
we do have a nice photo of Nakamura
wanna with Peter Svidler Peter Svidler
like it's from Leonard oh it's Instagram
account so he says that when fielder was
explaining to Caruana that he is lost in
the position and he was showing him all
the nice variations how he was lost so
as all of the other games were drawn in
round 4 by winning this game against by
winning this game against Nakamura
Caruana joins the leaders of the
tournament so after we show round 5
we're gonna check out the standing some
more and you know see see how this
tournament is going for everyone so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank mikaël de care
Benjamin Davidson Robert Stratford and
Douglas rife for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
thank you